moi ce qui est frappant c'est qu'en
effet il ya une stratégie industrielle
il ya surtout une gestion de ce qu'en
france on appelle le conflit d'intérêts
totalement différente puisque puisque
vous appuyer sur des experts qui
connaissent qu'ils connaissent alors
qu'on en a tendance parfois s'appuie sur
des gens qui disent je ne sais rien mais
je dirai tout donc c'est quand même une
réelle différence en matière de
stratégie industrielle et on voit aussi
les faits et puis j'aurai une question
aussi un peu parole est là est ce que
par rapport à ce qui a été une stratégie
vaccinale
il ya en ce moment au royaume-uni
quelque chose qui concerne le traitement
les médicaments de traitement du virus
au-delà des effets bénéfiques de la
vaccination
je vais passer la parole à rené paul
savary merci madame oui quelques
questions notamment
vous nous avez expliqué comment vous
aviez conçu cette stratégie vaccinale
l'achat de vaccins le développement etc
mais est-ce que vous êtes rapprocher
comme nous l'avons fait en france de
l'europe pour pour faire d un creux des
des achats groupés vous étiez en break
site est ce que c'est parce que c'était
le break site ou bien est ce que c'est
parce que il vous semblez plus compliqué
de travailler avec l'europe
un peu plus précisément peut-être savoir
comment vous avez participé aux autres
idées des différents candidats vaccins
pour cibler et labellisé notamment je
croise celui d'oxford astrazeneca et une
troisième question ce qui concerne le
nez va c'est l'entreprise nous a bien
dit que c'est le soutien du royaume uni
qui l'a qui lui a permis de poursuivre
le développement clinique de son vaccin
et cette société avait interrompu ses
noguez ses négociations avec l'europe
les jugeant trop complexe est-ce que
c'est également votre avis concernant la
difficulté à travailler sur le plan
européen va prendre deux autres
questions vous pourrez répondre ensuite
y en a une autre série de questions
élisabeth doineau et corinne imbert est
plus facile quoi alors déjà beaucoup de
questions alors nous nous rapprocher de
l'europe pour un approvisionnement après
visionnement groupe et quand je suis
arrivé en mai on m'a montré une lettre
qui venait je crois de la france qui
était une proposition
d'approvisionnement groupé entre la
france l'allemagne et on nous invitait à
rejoindre ce groupe et ça nous
intéressait oui ça nous intéresse
rejoindre ce groupe et on a mené des
discussions sur la manière dont on
pourrait participer à cela je crois à
accepter pour et bien l'alliance vaccins
et je crois que ça a été ensuite élargi
à l'italie et aux pays bas
mais d'après ce que je comprends la
commission européenne a établi que cette
alliance ne pourrait poursuivre se
poursuivre et que tout devait passer par
la commission européenne
c'est mon équipe internationale et non
moi même en particulier qui est bien à
et rester en contact et le message qui
nous a été donné c'est que oui nous
étions toujours dans l'europe et donc
nous pouvions participer à ce programme
d'approvisionnement groupé mais que nous
n'aurions pas la possibilité de
participer dans quelque décision que ce
soit ayant trait au vaccin et que nous
ne saurions pas quand nous recevrions
les vaccins ni quel vaccin et que nous
devions dès maintenant cesser toute
discussion avec des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et permettre à l'union
européenne de progresser de son côté
sans interférence j'ai vécu cela comme
effectivement des contraintes mais la
décision est venue du gouvernement qui a
considéré qu'il serait
et bien préférable pour nous de
continuer de notre côté plutôt que de
participer avec la commission européenne
donc ce n'était pas pendant le break 7 1
et donc ça n'avait pas de lien avec le
break 7 nous avions nous avons eu cette
opportunité de rejoindre ces procédures
mais nous avons décidé eux mais gare aux
contraintes de ne pas le faire la
deuxième question comment avons-nous
procéder au tri des vaccins et décidé de
donner la priorité à astrazeneca et bien
nous avons commencé donc un groupe
universitaire donc en janvier sur le
vaccin et des fonds ont été demandés en
février pour commencer à monter en
échelle notamment sur les essais
cliniques donc ça peut expliquer
pourquoi
et bien cet appui à la recherche
universitaire notamment par le fait que
le gouvernement a accordé des fonds à la
recherche clinique tld lui également
je pense que mes contacts avec
l'industrie de la biotech a permis de
travailler en étroite collaboration dès
février avec l'association delà des
bioindustries qu'est l'association donc
professionnels et ils savaient qu'ils
qu'ils auraient à soutenir les
entreprises qui allait monter en échelle
donc pour la fabrication des vaccins
donc ça va commencer en février
bien avant que en fait la cellule vaccin
soit lancée en mai alors nous avons mené
toute la diligence avec les experts et
les éléments clés
qu'elle nous sommes focalisés sur la
manière dont nous avons classés et
prioriser certains accents et bien
premier élément ô donc en 2020 est-ce
qu'ils allaient passer à la phase
clinique
s'il ne pouvait pas passer à la phase
clinique en 2020 nous n'allions pas
pouvoir être vraiment à l'avant boss tom
court et bien la fourniture de vaccins
pendant la pandémie deuxième aspect est
ce que nous pensions qu'ils allaient
pouvoir fabriquer à l'échelle pour avoir
suffisamment de doses pour pouvoir
protéger les personnes les plus
vulnérables troisième aspect ce que les
données précliniques et cliniques nous
indiquer et est-ce qu'elle était
convaincante en termes d'efficacité et
de sécurité
et est-ce qu'elle était basée sur les
mêmes formats pour pouvoir en déduire
commencé phaxan fonctionnel et déduit et
nous assurer de leur efficacité et de
leur innocuité et également il y a des
éléments très importante du domaine de
la qualité et du réglementaire de la
conforme de la conformité tout cela a
participé bien sûr mais ce n'était pas
je dirais les moteurs principaux et et
pour le prix nous avons au bout du
compte payer 10 livres 30 par doses ce
qui n'est pas tellement plus au bout du
compte que ce que l'union européenne a
payé
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que le prix
n'était pas le la première préoccupation
pour nous pour le financement
oui nous avons financé c'est
l'entreprise à la fois pour qu'elle
mette à l'échelle leur installation
mais la façon dont la signature des
contrats ça a fonctionné c'est que on a
donc débloqué des crédits dès le début
ça faisait partie du prépaiement pour
les 25 donc c'est un financement qui a
été en fait financer à risque et qui est
toujours un financement à risque parce
que nous ne savons toujours pas
véritablement pour certains de ses voeux
un sens si certains ne sont pas encore à
prouver et certains et bien non pas
encore prouvé leur efficacité mais si
elles sont approuvées et bien nous
utiliserons scène ce préfinancement que
le nous leur avons débloqué pour et bien
nous procurer des doses alors sur les
négociations avec menée par la
commission européenne et bien je ne peux
pas vous dire car je suis parti en
décembre 2001 il y avait une question
sur val nevins je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir compris la question pourriez
vous la reformuler s'il vous plaît panel
paul savary
oui c'était le financement de vannes et
vac que le royaume uni a a fait ou nous
avait expliqué que c'est en fait pour
pour l'industrialisation et val neva
nous disaient qu'ils avaient trouvé une
simplicité de discussions et de
financement avec vous plutôt qu'avec
l'union européenne et on voulait avoir
votre regard sur ces difficultés
rencontrées par l'europe mais j'aurais
aimé avoir des précisions sur suranné
vaste s'est fait vraiment très
rapidement si j'ai bien compris les
discussions c'est dur on était assez
direct et simple avec vale mais parce
que dans bien des cas nous connaissions
ces gens dont nous avions déjà travaillé
avec eux c'était en fait une entreprise
qui étaient appuyés par du
capital-risque à avant d'être donc
ensuite lancé et je connaissais moi avec
mes contacts dans la biotech beaucoup de
membres de l'équipe obl neva et il a
fait des capacités uniques il ya très
peu d'entreprises dans le monde si on
sort de la chine et de la russie et qui
peuvent et bien fabriquer ce qu'ils
fabriquent et c'est une discussion
importante pour nous et les discussions
étaient ma foi très claire et directe
eux avaient besoin de d'augmenter leurs
capacités et nous on leur fournissait en
retour la possibilité d'avoir des essais
cliniques et je ne peux pas vous dire
vous en dire plus sur les négociations
avec la commission européenne car ce
n'était pas de mon fait très bien merci
madame élisabeth doineau oui merci
madame la présidente merci madame pour
l'ensemble de votre présentation est
également les réponses que vous venez
d'apporter alors moi je vais vous
demander quelques précisions
la première des précisions c'est qu'elle
est en fait quelle a été votre marge
d'autonomie on voit bien que votre
groupe était un groupe resserré que seul
lui a donné beaucoup d'agilité que vous
étiez relier directement avec le premier
ministre mais qu'elle était justement
votre capacité à comment a décidé en
quelque sorte des candidats vaccins à
soutenir et des industriels avec
lesquels contracté vos propositions ont
elles été facilement acceptée et validée
par le gouvernement britannique
on a senti que c'était à priori une
réalité mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des détails
avez vous associez les départements
ministériels de l'économie et de la
santé
très en amont pour vous assurer que le
gouvernement validerait les choix que
vous proposeriez vous nous avez parlé
effectivement du ministère de l'économie
mais on entend peu parler du ministère
de la santé et les ministères vous
ont-ils imposer des plafonds de dépenses
ou vous ont-ils laissé une certaine
marge de manoeuvre dans c'est toujours
la question de l'autonomie pour la
négociation des prix pour avec les
industriels ma deuxième précision est la
suivante pourriez vous revenir sur les
adaptations des procédures
d'autorisation et d'accès aux marchés
que vous avez envisagé pour garantir un
déploiement rapide de la vaccination au
royaume uni avez vous alerte et très tôt
l' agence du médicament britanniques
pour qu'elles se préparent suffisamment
tôt à examiner les demandes
d'autorisation des industriels avec
lesquels vous négocier des contrats et
vu quel bilan faites-vous de la
réactivité de l' agence du médicament
pour autoriser les vaccins au royaume
uni merci la info madame
[Musique]
aucune alliance avec la science alors
encore beaucoup de questions
alors je vis en changer un petit peu
l'ordre si vous le voulez bien
la limite de nos dépenses vous allez
demander quel était notre marge
d'autonomie sur les négociations sur les
prix et bien la première chose que nous
avons faite en juin a été d'avancer
si vous voulez l'argumentaire commercial
par lequel nous avancions la stratégie
de notre approche en par portefeuille
c'est à dire nous allons acheter douze
vaccins différents et nous avons donc
réalisé les études de cas pousser et
danses et ses études de cas et ses
argumentaires assez poussées et bien
nous présentions des enveloppes
envisagée alors ça n'était pas basé sur
des faits puisque aucune de ces
entreprises fabricantes de vaccins ayant
développé un vaccin ne savait et bien
calé quelles seraient les coûts mais
c'était basé sur des estimations qui
était basé sur le médecin auxois
astrazeneca dont nous savions qu'ils
allaient être relativement peu onéreux à
fabriquer et sur cette base nous avons
réalisé des estimations sur les vaccins
arn messager dont nous savions qu'ils
allaient être plus onéreux et donc nous
nous sommes rapprochés du trésor au sein
du gouvernement nous leur avons présenté
notre argumentaire commercial en leur
disant voilà nous pensons
ce que sera l'enveloppent que nous
allons dépenser et donc l'idée s'était
en fait de vraiment réservé sanctuariser
même si vous voulez et bien cette
enveloppe de dépenses de manière à ne
plus avoir à en discuter ultérieurement
cet argent avait été d'ores et déjà et
bien mis de côté alors sur ses
estimations et bien c'était les
meilleures estimations que nous pussions
à avoir est réalisé à ce moment alors
sur notre autonomie vous demander quel
était notre degré d'autonomie notre
autonomie était totale
et ça c'était absolument essentiel pour
moi quand j'ai accepté de mener cette
cellule vax je voulais avoir totale
autonomie et l'idée était de pouvoir
et bien sûr tous les vaccins que nous
avions examiné faire une due diligence
sur 20 et en sélectionner cette les
décisions sur les 25 nous allions
choisit bien nous avons décidé ce que
nous allons proposer aux
au comité d'investissement du
gouvernement et ses trucs qu'ils ont
fait ensuite pris les décisions de
dépenses mais c'était sur la base de nos
recommandations
nous avons eu de très bonnes discussions
avec les ministres comme je l'aurais
fait moi dans mon entreprise de
capital-risque vous savez quand je fais
des recommandations d'investissement je
dis clairement quels sont les risques
les opportunités les raisons pour
lesquelles je pense qu'on doit le faire
on devrait le faire les raisons pour
lesquelles je pense line2 aujourd'hui ne
pas le faire donc
et donc avec le trésor et le ministère
de la santé
oui nous avons eu des discussions bien
sûr par le biais des différents comités
et en particulier le comité et de du
programme et jansen van damme qui est
donc notre conseiller médical en chef
qui était donc au sein de notre comité
de pilotage et il avait des des
discussions tous les matins en fait à 8
heures du matin il tombe s'il suivait ça
de très très près nous avons travaillé
avec le trésor pour donc ça c'est avec
le département de la santé
mais nous avons également travaillé avec
le trésor nous avons informé des
contrats qui avaient été signés
également du calendrier et de
et bien tout le cadrage en ont tous les
termes du contrat
toutes les modalités du contrat donc oui
nous avons travaillé avec eux certes
mais au bout du compte les négociations
et la définition des modalités des
contrats c'est nous qui l'avons mené ses
manies m ammann qui est très
expérimentés venant de 2 du système de
des banques est également avec une
expérience gouvernementale
alors vous aviez aussi une question sur
le mhr a sur l' agence du médicament
bien sûr nous les avons informés de ce
que nous faisions mais nous n'avons pas
été impliqués dans les rues dans les
discussions entre les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et le mhr a car ces
discussions sont privés entre les
développent les développeurs de vaccins
et le régulateur et john wayne qui est à
la tête du mhr à a développé ce concept
de d'examen glissons si vous voulez qui
a permis d'avoir cette flexibilité dans
l'ue l'évaluation de l'efficacité et de
la sécurité du vaccin
nous avons pu tirer parti du règlement
1,7 trois usages d'urgence mais c'était
déjà disponibles c'est vrai mais il y à
une consultation pour ajouter des
conditions supplémentaires à toute
autorisation d'utilisation d'urgence
donc nous n'avons pas a dit om et cher 1
qu'il devait travailler rapidement ils
le savaient et
il était déjà très efficace si vous
regardez les calendriers qui ont été
rendus publics sur la rapidité avec
laquelle ils ont approuvé les vaccins
pour les essais cliniques sur la base
des essais cliniques ils ont été
extrêmement rapide
donc je pense qu'ils ont été très
efficaces et oui nous étions en étroite
collaboration il savait ce que nous
faisions mais nous n'avons bien sûr pas
participer aux discussions qu'ils
avaient que ce soit avec les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques ou pour
l'autorisation
voilà merci alors nous allons prendre
quatre questions rapide concise puisque
l'impératif dont corinne imbert laurence
garnier michel meunier l'année chaque
main et madame répondra à la totalité
question corinne mercier l'épisode bon
alors je vais faire peut-être que cours
que je l'aurais imaginé mais je vais
revenir donc du coup sur le registre
national des volontaires
vous avez innové pour convaincre les
industriels de conclure des contrats
d'approvisionnement en proposant l'accès
un registre national de volontaires
prêts à participer les effets des essais
cliniques
comment vous est venue cette idée
dans quelle mesure l'accès à ce registre
at il intéressé industriels et quelles
sont les conditions d'accès a surgi ce
que vous avez définies notamment pour
protéger la sécurité des données de
santé sujet dont on parle beaucoup dans
notre pays et d'une façon générale le
royaume uni at il organisé un suivi en
vie réelle des personnes à qui des
vaccins ont été inoculés je crois que
cela représente 500 mille personnes est
ce que vous pouvez me ne me confirmer le
chiffre là je reviendrai pas sur la
remarque assez la présidente entre d'un
côté les clés de la réussite rapidité
expertise quand dans notre pays on parle
principe de précaution et liens
d'intérêts des experts
je vous remercie laurence garnier
oui merci madame la présidente merci à
vous pour cette présentation on a bien
compris un certain nombre de différences
de stratégie entre le royaume uni d'un
côté la france et l'union européenne de
l'autre à la fois en termes de moyens
financiers de production de mise à
disposition de moyens de production et
puis aussi en termes de diversification
des vaccins sur lesquels vous avez misé
je pense bien sûr à vannes mais va donc
à parler mon collègue rené paul savary
mais aussi à beaucoup d'autres que vous
avez présenté tout à l'heure dans le
diaporama
quel est le paysage des vaccins
disponibles aujourd'hui au royaume uni
par rapport à la france sont à trois
vaccins en circulation moderne à pfizer
et bien sûr astrazeneca est est ce que
cette stratégie de diversification
présente aujourd'hui des opportunités ou
des difficultés ou présentera demain des
opportunités ou des difficultés à deux
niveaux d'abord par rapport aux
populations en termes de résistance
possible de certaines populations à tel
type de vaccin par rapport à tel autre
et puis également en termes de
résistance aux variants que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui auxquels vous
êtes confrontés la france commence à
l'être également
merci michel magne m merci madame la
présidente rapidement merci madame binga
de tous les propos que vous avez tenus
moi j'irai comme mes collègues sur la
stratégie quand vous nous avez dit que
la cellule vaccin était sous l'autorité
du premier ministre et du ministre des
affaires industrielles et pas celui de
la santé ça résume parfaitement la
direction de la stratégie que vous avez
retenu et qui visiblement donc à ce
succès que vous connaissez et que nous
constatons donc un mot sur ce sur cette
stratégie et on regarde ce qui se passe
en europe
votre
analyse peut-être deux en tout cas la
stratégie française notamment est votre
regard là-dessus
et puis je voulais aussi vous demander
au début vous avez essuyé beaucoup de
critiques
est-ce que c'était le fait de cette
organisation où c'était le fait que ce
soit dirigé par une femme
merci à l'exact même oui merci madame la
présidente majoré de 36 de questions il
y en a une qui rejoint celle de ma
collègue l'une des préoccupations
actuelles du boris johnson et le
vaillant delta anciennement variant
indien qui semble beaucoup plus
contagieux que les autres ces derniers
jours il a annoncé retarder la dernière
phase du plan de déconfinement de quatre
semaines le temps que plus de personnes
en bénéficient d'aidés deux doses de
vaccin à votre année la france doit elle
s'inquiéter ou dans une moindre mesure
sachant qu'ici on a plus vaccinée avec
pfizer et modern art qui semble plus
résistants à ce variant et puis vous
avez dit vous nous avez dit que vous
aviez racheter une entreprise de
fabrication du vaccin vétérinaire vous
êtes vous appuyez sur les vétérinaires
ou leurs techniques expertise par
exemple dans la gestion ou la mise en
place de tests
vous savez qu'en france on a longuement
tardé à utiliser les laboratoires
vétérinaires ou aussi dans la gestion
épidémique puisque là aussi les vétos
l'habitude de gérer des épis divisé à
grande échelle la voilà merci bien
toutes les questions un peu madame ok
alors la première question c'est sur ce
registre du nhs de volontaires est-ce
que c'était important
elle la réponse est cédée crucial
critique
c'était très très clair quand l école on
réouvert et les universités et bien on
s'attendait à ce que le taux d'infection
remonte à l'automne ce qui a été le cas
et donc nous voulions être en mesure de
montrer aux entreprises de vaccins que
nous étions en mesure de recruter les
gens très rapidement donc oui ces
entreprises était très intéressé à
l'idée d'avoir le bénéfice de de pouvoir
compter sur ce registre de patients
incluant des patients âgés et ailleurs
je crois que ça a été menée mardi via
qui était dans mon équipe
elle fait partie de du bras de recherche
du nhs on en a parlé en juin et on a
lancé un test bêta début juillet et on
l'a lancé publiquement le 20 et 21
juillet novavax a été le premier à
l'utiliser même si ce fut là un petit
peu utilisé novamex a été ensuite la
première entreprise à l'utiliser et ça
leur a permis de commencer et de finir
là le l'essai de phase iii avant même
que les états unis et commencé leurs
études de phase iii donc le recrutement
était tellement rapide que ils ont pu
ensuite l'étendre et dès janvier on
savait que
vingt-cinq été très efficace alors la
protection des données personnelles
et bien c'est le nhs et tout ça t'a
technologies numériques que du nhs qui a
géré cela donc aucune donnée personnelle
de patientes a été partagée au rendu
public les personnes recevaient des
emails en disant vous êtes maintenant
éligibles pour un essai et mais johnson
johnson va on y va on utilisait ce
registre et y en a maintenant d'autres
entreprises qui l'utilisent elle
améliore dont cela a fonctionné c'est
que l'entreprise donc développeurs de
vaccins disait eh bien voilà les gens
que nous voulons cibler que ce soit des
minorités ethniques ou des personnes
avec des comorbidités et eh bien c'était
donc
ces patients qui recevaient un email
pour leur dire vous êtes éligible
donc il n'y avait absolument aucune
donnée personnelle d'échangés c'était
tout à fait à anonymiser pour la
diversification de notre portefeuille et
l'inclusion de valve neva et donc et
bien par rapport à ce que vous avez vous
comme vaccin en france eh bien c'est
exactement ce que nous avions et donc
pour le vaccin à base de protéines
as-tu vente est très efficace mais nous
ne l'avons pas dans notre portefeuille
pour ce qui est des difficultés
notamment de personnes réfractaires
nous nous avons noté une une adhésion
très importante
en fait on s'est rendu compte que par
rapport à 25 de la grippe classique où
on a 75 % d'acceptation et bien donc on
était au delà et un nouveau vaccin en
scène sont approuvées au royaume uni en
tout cas nos vaccins et il n'y a eu
aucun problème pour que les gens aient
bien décide de se faire vacciner
donc très peu de réfractaires votre
question suivante était le que nous
ayons choisi d'être placé sous
l'autorité de du ministère de la
stratégie industrielle et non du
ministère de la santé bien je crois que
notre stratégie était de d'acheter et
d'évaluer des vaccins et donc nous nous
basions sur des experts du développement
de
ainsi nos ventes et nous les achetions
ensuite ces vaccins et de métiers
ensuite en en place un plan pour nous
assurer d'être mieux préparés pour
d'éventuelles pandémies futur cd ça
notre stratégie est donc nous devions
prouver notre capacité à trier ses
vaccins à les sélectionner et à en
tester l'efficacité et je pense que
c'est la bonne approche
alors je n'ai pas de commentaire sur la
stratégie en france car je regrette
d'avoir à dire que je n'ai pas suivi
cette stratégie de très près mais je
pense que la manière dont nous avons
lancé les choses étaient la bonne
approche alors par rapport aux critiques
que j'ai reçus au royaume-uni j'ai été
critiqué parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
méfiance de la part des politiques de
faire venir quelqu'un du secteur privé
pour travailler avec le gouvernement de
qu'il ya beaucoup d'accusations de
conflit d'intérêts qui étaient fausses
parce que j'ai suivi et bien toute la
procédure concernant les conflits
d'intérêts comme n'importe quel
fonctionnaire ou personnes travaillant
avec le réguler le gouvernement leur
effet y aussi le fait que je suis mariée
à un mini serait due qui est à
l'intérieur de département du trésor au
royaume uni donc on a considéré que
j'avais peut-être été parachuté par les
conservateurs et moi je n'ai pas
d'opinion politique et donc je n'ai pas
été parachuté par les conservateurs pour
le variant delta parce que vous avez
indiqué que pfizer et moderne a été plus
résistants aux variants delta ce n'est
pas le cas elle les dernières données
dont notre agence england donc ces
dernières données hausse
oxford visiblement à une efficacité de
92% contre pfizer à 96 % par rapport aux
valves orient delta donc il n'ya pas une
différence importante
et le fait est que tous les vaccins que
nous disposons actuellement sont
efficaces contre se mariant ça c'est
extrêmement important de le dire
et moi j'ai toute confiance que s'il
regarde l'état des lieux actuel je pense
fermement que l'europe a les outils
nécessaires pour contrer cette pandémie
et nous avons des outils peut-être
différent c'est que nous nous avons la
possibilité de faire un mélange
vaccinale nous avons autorisé à ce que
la première injection et la deuxième
injection ne soit pas le même vaccin est
donc l'idée d'avoir un rappel de vaccin
qui soit avec un autre vaccin élite
donné que nous avons sur les premiers
essais cliniques qui ont été réalisés
sur ces mélanges vaccinaux sont très
très encourageante et nous avons
également la possibilité de
d'administrer une troisième injection
soit avec le même vaccin soit avec un
autre vaccin cela fait partie si vous
voulez de notre boîte à outils pour
protéger contre les variants et et le
dernière instruments et bien nous avons
la possibilité de changer les vaccins
eux-mêmes et donc
dans ces vaccins basés sur un virus
inactivé ou sur la rn messager et vient
pour ce qui est des arriérés de messages
et on peut modifier la séquence
génétique et est donc maintenant il faut
attendre de voir si les autorités
régulatrices vont compresser les
procédures d'autorisation pour permettre
à ces vaccins donc modifié de pouvoir
être approuvé très rapidement sur
l'utilisation des vétérinaires
nous n'avons pas utilisé ces
vétérinaires et ses sites de fabrication
de production mais oui le royaume uni a
fait appel aux vétérinaires retour à la
vaccination ton comme le déploiement de
la campagne vaccinale a bénéficié du
concours des vétérinaires à côté de
beaucoup d'autres personnes qui sont
devenues vaccinateurs et qui ont
participé au développement de la
campagne vaccinale
je crois avoir répondu à toutes les
questions
[Musique]